All right. Hello everybody. Uh, welcome
to my short series on buying and selling
items in freetoplay Runescape. Yeah, so
I made a brand new account here. You can
see I'm just going through tutorial
island uh just to show that my goal here
is going to be getting a bond. And it is
totally possible in freeto play. You
don't actually have to use any of your
own actual money. That is if you have
the time for it because this will take a
little while, but I believe this is one
of the quickest ways in freeto play to
make money. Um, so yeah, we're just
going to finish tutorial island here.
Going to go mess with this imp a little
bit. Um, but yeah, so we just have to go
to the Grand Exchange. We're going to
sell off all the items we have and then
just gather a little bit more coin just
to get a,000 GP just cuz it's even
number and it's easier for me to see how
much I start with and what I end with.
Yep. So, I'll see you at the Grand
Exchange. All right. So, we actually had
to go finish a couple quests just to
have access to the Grand Exchange.
Totally forgot about that. But yeah, so
we're jumping right into it. We have a
thousand gold. We were trying to come up
with a good item to start with. Now, my
first thought was runes. And that turns
out to not be the best idea. I was
trying to do something safe because I
didn't want to get stuck with an item I
couldn't sell and just be over right
away. So, I tried to start with runes.
Now, the reason this isn't a good idea
is because sure, I will very
consistently be getting one GP off each
rune. I mean, let's see. I can buy just
a couple hundred runes. I mean, I would
make
probably couple hundred GP, but this
could take a couple hours and this would
just take way too long. I really need an
item that will kind of exponentially
grow my money a little bit more just to
start with. So, I abandon that pretty
quickly. Uh, we went and checked a
couple other items like arrows and
lobsters, but we did find this really
good item, monkey bones. It's used in
the monkey madness quest. I ended up
buying quite a few of these, 30 or 40,
and the margin was massive. Like, it was
people were selling them for 30, I
believe, is what I put in. And they were
still selling for about 400 GP each. Uh,
so I'm going to just put this offer in
here, and if they sell, that'd be great.
it would really expedite the process of
starting the series. Uh so I can
actually have a bit of starting cash.
Yeah. So we're just going to leave these
in for a couple hours here and I will
come check back with you when they
bought. All right. Um so that really
didn't take nearly as long as I thought
it was going to. We bought them in about
half an hour maybe and we just decided
to sell off a couple as soon as we
could. Um so we sold we bought 30 of
them and we sold the 23 for about almost
10k. Uh, and we have seven left to sell.
So, it's getting pretty late here. So,
what I'm going to do is just put in
another offer for Monkey Bones. There's
no reason not to. There isn't some sort
of taboo against buying the same item
over and over again. Even look at that
margins even lower, like 13 and selling
for 400. That's that's not going to
happen very frequently. So, I might as
well take advantage of it. So, I'm going
to leave it in overnight and just see
how many I can buy. I'm not expecting to
buy them all, but we'll see. Maybe I
would be really happy if I do. But
either way, for every monkey bone I buy,
I'm making
about 400 GP almost. Yeah. So, we'll
leave these in overnight. Sell the rest
of the ones we have and I'll check in
with you guys uh in the
morning. All right. Uh so, we woke up
this morning and it looks like we bought
about 60 of the monkey bones. So, that's
still great. I really didn't expect to
buy all of them. Uh but we sold off the
rest of the ones we had. And when we do
sell these monkey bones, we'll be
getting about 25k. So that is great. I
went and checked the margin again this
morning. It's not as good anymore. It's
still relatively good compared to
free-to-play items cuz there's not a big
item pool. This is actually a good item
still, but I'm going to mix it up. Okay,
so uh yeah, the next item we're going to
pick is going to be still a quest
related item as the monkey bones did do
well. So we're going to pick a red dye.
I think it's only used for a couple
free-to-play quests, but if someone
needs it, they're not gonna they're not
going to wait for them to get the best
price. They're just gonna put as much in
as they need because they just want the
quest done. It's not like they're going
to buy multiple of these. So, it's not
going to be a fast moving item, but
people still do need it. So, I'm going
to be making I think the margin was
about 300 on these ones. So, not as good
as the monkey bones, but this is going
to be more accurate how freeto play
items are going to go. So, we're going
to put an offer for six, and I'll just
come check back when the monkey bones
have sold. All right, see you in a bit.
All right, so it looks like all our
monkey bones have sold. We sold 60 of
them for 420 each, which is going to
bring our cash stack up to about 25k
minus the couple items we have as well.
Uh, so going forward from here, the
monkey bones, the margins not as good
anymore. So, we're going to move into
another item. And the dyes are they're
okay, but they're not very quick moving.
So, we're not really sure which way we
should go. We would like to eventually
buy some of the trimmed armor because it
does have good margins on those and that
could really help us exponentially grow
a bit more cuz these red dyes aren't the
greatest. I just want want to have offer
slots filled. So, we're going to put in
kind of a legacy offer for the monkey
bones just cuz they have been jumping
around quite a bit. And we're going to
buy some more of the red dyes. But we
are looking for a better item to go
forward with because going this way will
take a long time. So yeah, we're going
to look for another
item. All right, so uh we bought and
sold a couple more of the red dives. Uh
we're still buying them for about 862
and selling them for about 200 GP
profit. So we're just going to go pop
the rest of these in here. So if we do
sell those, I mean, it's it's pretty
good for what I'm at still. 200 GP times
20 be
4,000. Yeah, 4,000. Uh, yes. So, yeah,
we're going to try these a couple more
times. And we just need to find one more
item to fill our last slot. We do leave
the monkey bones in there. We're kind of
just holding on the hope. I don't think
it's going to pan out into anything, but
again, it is hard to find items in
freeto play, so we might as well leave
some offers in there because you never
know.
So yeah, we're going to put in just a
smaller offer for the monkey bones. Then
we do look for another item that has a
high margin on it and we'll sell quickly
enough, but it doesn't have to be a very
fast moving item because I won't be able
to buy that many of them. So we try
lobsters. Didn't pan out to work. So
next item we're going to try is a
fishing net. So after the checking the
fishing net's margins, it look like it
has about a 60 GP margin on it, which is
really good for how much it costs. So,
realistically, these won't sell very
quickly, but I should be able to still
buy 50 of them and sell them reasonably
quick. So, yeah, we'll leave that in for
a little while, and I'll check back uh
when I bought some of the fishing
nets. All right, so it's been a couple
hours. Uh, so it looks like we managed
to sell all the red dyes. We made about
4k or something off of that. the the
fishing nets we're going to sell here
shortly. We just want to recheck the
margin. And one thing I noticed is they
didn't seem to be I wasn't able to buy
any. So that doesn't necessarily mean no
one's selling them. Uh cuz it can change
by what world you're in, I think. But we
did put an offer in for 3,000, which we
that would be awful of a bot. But that
basically is just telling us that at
least at this time, no one is selling
fishing nets besides us. So we got a
little cheeky. We're putting them in for
a,000. Kind of just hoping for the best.
Even if I sold one of those for a,000,
it'd be amazing. But we'll see. And
we'll leave this in here and check back
and see if any of those actually managed
to
sell. All right, so unfortunately, we
didn't manage to sell any of the fishing
nets for 1,000 each. Not a big shocker,
really. So, we ended up selling them for
the original plan, which was about 30 GP
profit on each one. So, that'll bring us
another 2K. So, nothing great, but we're
still making money. Still trying to save
up for to be able to afford a couple
pieces of trimmed armor to try to flip.
So, we're going to go continue on with
fishing nets because they do actually
buy pretty quick and sell pretty quick.
On top of that, we do try to find
another item, maple logs, which is my
first kind of attempt at a high volume
kind of low margin flip. So, we'll see
how that goes. I'm going to put in an
offer of 30GP to buy them. It looked
like there was a 4GP margin, which is
pretty decent for how cheap the item is.
So, yeah, we'll put in an offer. I think
we put in 300 maple logs or something.
Oh, wait. No, 600. So, we put that in
and we'll leave that. And on top of
that, we're going to find one more item
and we're going to try the amulet of
magic, which I have flipped in the past
and does actually work pretty well. So,
we go and check the margin. And while
it's not massive, I I have known the
amulet of magics to be a lot more
expensive. So, we're going to buy some
and maybe the price will rise up. If
not, we'll still be making about a 70gp
profit on each
one, which isn't that great, but if they
do rise up, cuz I'm going to leave this
in overnight, uh it'll help us make a
bit more. So, we're going to put an
offer of about 20 of them, and we're
going to go to
bed. All right, so we managed to sell
off the rest of the items. We had uh the
fishing nets and amulet of magic didn't
make a whole lot off of them. I mean,
amulet magics probably made like
1.5k and the fishing nets made like
2.5k. So, we're going to kind of steer
clear of these. It wasn't really worth
the time it took to sell them. I mean,
the amulets were not so bad, but the
fishing nets kind of took forever. So,
we're going to try to find another item
here. We're going to try shears. And
this is going to be the
last kind of lame item we're going to
try, but it does have a quite a big
margin on it. I I bought it for about
15. It can sell for about
300. Yep. So, 15. So, we're going to put
an offer in for that. I'll leave those.
Who knows? We just want to have our
offer slots filled up. So, now we're
finally going to move on to something a
little more interesting. We're going to
try uh a trimmed piece of armor. So, I
don't really have the money to actually
check the margin myself. So, I actually
used OS Buddy Exchange, which is a
little more accurate than the actual
Runescape exchange website. So, I
checked it. I had a really good margin
on the admin plate
G. So, what we're going to do is we're
going to put an offer for about 8,300.
We can buy about four of them. So, this
a little risky, but it could have a
really good
payoff. I believe we could buy them for
8,300. selling. It's going to be kind of
hard to know, but even if we made a
couple K profit on each one, that'd be
amazing. So, we're going to leave these
in for a little while and I will come
and check back and see if they've
bought. Wow. So, we bought these
insanely quickly. It really did not take
that long. It was a couple hours at
most. And we just put an offer in just
to gauge. We're going to slowly bring it
down, but they sold for 20K. That's like
13k right off that one piece of armor.
So, we're going to go put 25,000. I
mean, why not? We can just reduce it
down. We have all our money invested in
this, but 13k on each one. If we sell
that, we'll be over 100k. So, yeah,
we're going to try this again. I'll
leave this in for a while and hopefully
we sell them all because that'd be
amazing. Look at that. Oh my god. So,
yeah, we're going to go try to find one
more item to put in here. I can friend
do shears again. I'm so surprised that
actually happened. So, we'll put in
another offer for shears and hopefully
the rest of these will sell for 25k
because that would bring that would help
us so much. I mean, we would have triple
quadrupled our money right there. So,
yeah, we kind of lucked out on that. I'm
not sure if these are going to sell for
20k again, but if they do, that's
great. Actually sold them all for 23k.
That's amazing right there. That's 15,
30, 60k I made just on the admin plate
bodies. I mean, that's like doubling and
tripling my money. So, wow. So, we're
over 100k. I think this is where we're
going to stop the first episode. So, we
started from a thousand. It was a bit
slow at the start, but it's starting to
ramp up. And I'm actually surprised.
There's some really good freetoplay
items. Uh, so I didn't actually expect
it to go this
quickly. So, yeah. Um, we'll going to
start working on episode two. Uh, if you
did like the video, appreciate a like.
Any feedback would be appreciated and I
will see you guys in the next episode.